[Music]
a warm welcome to the design education
Summit
2023 congratulations to design Singapore
for organizing I must really thank you
for championing design thinking in our
schools and in The Wider Singapore I'm
so happy to see design Singapore working
on this closely with Moe and many other
like-minded partners including industry
Partners who are here today for us to
embark on this journey to inculcate the
design thinking skills in our students
starting from Young design is not just
about some fancy products but also is
about processes policies plans design is
not just about being functional it's
about engaging inspiring and
connecting as you experience this design
Summit you're going to see and
appreciate iate how creativity runs
through design as a bridge we're going
to explore design literacy as an
important competency that everyone could
learn we're also going to explore how
we're going to empower the new
generation of young change makers as
positive change makers that can solve
the railro problems no matter how young
they are educators are futurist
Educators must prepare students to
thrive in a world that does not exist
that we as Educators we teach the p
we need to get better at teaching the
future you are the futurist your student
needs I'm going to persuade you that
design is an
advantage and if every student every
worker every company designs better we
will have a better Singapore this is
your message that you can bring back uh
to your schools your institutions or
maybe even your
[Music]
companies
because great design makes lives so much
better and this is why design sangro
council is committed to design education
this is why we're committed to a design
education Summit for educators please
continue to work with us to make lives
better by design build more lovable
communities by Design so that we can
build a nation by design by nurturing
the next generation of change
[Applause]
makers